kristen troftinson wikileaks chief
editor thank you very much for joining
us on the program uh so
it's known that julian assange attempted
to warn hillary clinton now over a
series of sensitive cables what weight
do you think that that latest tape
uh adds
well this should have a tremendous
weight because it basically throws out
the
argument that is in the narrative of the
justice department in the their
indictment and which they are trying to
use
to get them extradited out of the uk
they are talking about
irresponsible behavior and putting lives
at risk
now this evidence that you heard and i
can confirm that this is authentic
is not new to the courts in the uk
transcript of
this conversation was presented to the
court in september
it shows that that julian assange did
take
take action to try to prevent the
release of the unredacted cables
this was nine months into the project
though at wikileaks was very carefully
administering the release of these
diplomatic peoples in
conjunction and with the help of 100
plus media partners
this was not under the julian's control
or wikileaks control this was betrayal
by a former partner
and a betrayal by a former media partner
the guardian
now this would show that there was great
caretaking and trying to avoid any harm
and assisted provided or
offered to mitigate any possible harm
but that offer was was ignored the state
department never came back to julian for
more
information and seemed to have not done
anything based on this warning and keep
in mind that this is not
the allegation is that julian uh and
wikileaks published the unredacted
diplomatic cables 20 50 000 of them
in september of 2011.
but wikileaks and julian were not the
primary publisher
of the this material at that time it has
been established
and it's undisputed that an american
based
website called kryptom.org was a primary
publisher
the secondary publisher was a
pirate bay who put that in a torrent or
online
so only after that did wikileaks put the
entire cache of cables online after
all these warnings to the state
departments which was not the first
warning there was an offer almost a year
earlier to the state department
to cooperate so it totally goes against
the narrative in the indictments
and totally goes to show that wikileaks
and julian assange
were behaving like a very responsible
publisher of the material
yeah well like you said there have been
you know there were a lot of unheated
warnings that the u.s state department
could have uh given some attention to
but why do you think that they were they
were seemingly so
uninterested in talking to assange about
it
there can only be speculations but the
evidence is there
it's a 75 minute long conversation with
a lawyer at the state department
who seemed grateful to get the call
actually and for all the information
that was presented to him where it was
in detail
explained why this came about through
through a
betrayal of a former employee
who was dismissed from his post a year
earlier
in combination with the the guardian
journalist mistake
which actually published a password to
uh
encrypted file containing these
documents uh
in a book so the assistance was
offered to to stop this
or mitigate any any possible harm to
this
it is i have no idea why this was not
followed through and they took off the
offer of
of the help that julian was was
carefully and
considerably uh worried in in
offering to the state department i
wanted to bring the discussion to the
expected ruling
on uh assange's potential extradition to
the united states it's due in january uh
do you think that this tape
could influence the result of that
ruling
i don't know if it's gonna influence the
ruling on on january 4th
it should it's one of the absolutely
overwhelming
evidence against the united states
case in its entirety uh there are so
many elements that
that are are on in julian's favor there
and all this was presented
mind you in the long court sessions in
september until the beginning of october
so it should
help in in in in
the ruling in julian's favor and against
the extradition
whether that's going to happen or not we
just remains to be seen
and what do you think the influence of
uh biden sitting in the white house
rather than trump sitting in the white
house is going to have on the
extradition and if he is extradited to
the united states what kinds of
consequences he would face
well that's an unknown entity we don't
know
the composition in full of the uh
incoming administration
uh it is very hard to to to see what
kind of
what direction that administration will
take
in terms of how they view julian assange
and snowden for that matter there have
been
attempts to get a clarity on on from in
the biden camp of what they think about
the
issue there but that has not uh
delivered anything so we don't know what
the position will be
there are very strong elements
[Music]
in the u.s pushing for this case you
could call it the deep states or
or or those who were seeking vengeance
but on the other hand at the same time
now
there's a bipartisan rather strong
urging by individuals on donald trump to
actually pardon him before
he leaves the white house well
looking more generally now what do you
think what kind of impact do you think
this lengthy legal saga surrounded
uh you know surrounding assange is going
to have on uh
you know the way the legal system and
the way society looks at whistleblowers
like them
i believe it might have had a cooling
effect and a chilling effect
and especially on on journalists who are
seeing this unfolding in front of their
eyes
the serious implication it will have for
their work especially if they are
reporting on national
security issues anywhere in the world
they would not be safe if julian is
extradited
and the simple fact that he is now being
persecuted in the manner he is is
undoubtedly
sending a chilling effect and it could
have an effect on whistleblowers as well
but on the other hand we've seen great
examples of whistleblowers taking
extreme courageous extremely courageous
decision
in stepping forward and serving the
public
when they see that higher ideals are
being abused
well i also wanted to ask if you've been
in contact with julian assange as of
late do you have any do you have
anything have you heard anything from
him recently
i mean you know the his his condition
there's not that much information about
it
i haven't heard from him directly for a
few weeks
but up indirectly through his uh his
fiancee and and a few other individuals
that he is in
more easier contact with and the lawyers
the situation is bad
the covet is now rampant inside
belmore's prison
which means that he has to spend his
days
in isolation in the cell now
on top of that it's freezing now in the
uk
he has to stack books in the the window
to keep the cold outs he hasn't been
supplied with his winter clothes
he got a couple of blankets a couple of
days ago which helped a lot but
this is a porn situation and
just imagine that we're getting into
christmas and
with a a publisher and a journalist
sitting in belmore's prison for
simply doing the job job of journalism
that is
simply unacceptable in a western
democracy or
any country for that matter well it
seems like horrific conditions for a
prison in in the developed world you
know
um i wanted to ask just one more
question uh about the legacy that you
think assange and his work will leave
uh you know his work with wikileaks what
do you think the legacy is going to be
i mean i absolutely certain i've been
with wikileaks for 10 years through all
all throughout all this term turmoil and
this terminus period
there is no doubt in my mind that we are
on the right side of history history
will
uh come to the conclusion when the smoke
clears
that the contribution of julian assange
to journalism
has been extraordinary it has been a
transformative effect on on
how we conduct journalism it has
expanded the scope of it
and been absolutely revolutionary that
will be accepted uh
more thoroughly in the future uh so i i
don't doubt that the future will be a
good judge when it comes to julia
sauce's contribution
kristen raffensen wikileaks chief editor
thank you very much for joining us on
the program
thanks for having me